reading speaking of reading thanks for
the page number that lets me know it's a
totally real book about make-believe
things what is it that makes a man a man
narration by John Hurt is still
narration
combining science and black magic
because black magic alone isn't good
enough it all began in 1944 who he goes
through the trouble of having John Hurt
set the stage but omit it just enough
narration so we need text with a date
and location allowing it to hit three
expositional cliches in the first minute
well then slowly introduces a rosary so
we know some spiritual is about to go
down but they won't actually be useful
to anyway there's nothing on this island
with chiefin rocks
ruins not rock the remains of Toronto
may be built on an intersection of ley
lines room uses this opportunity to
explain why they're on the island
instead of earlier during the planning
phase of this mission also the Nazis are
conducting magical experiments on a
remote island you'd think they'd want to
keep that a secret
it looks like they unfurled the banner
right away a freak in the gas mask car
Cronan this world war ii general is
unaware who hitler's top assassin is
he's yeah this is less than I thought
did anyone do any pre-planning before
this mission or they just winging it at
this point five years on a sachet god
how much expositional yelling can we
cram into this movie the Nazis
discovered pokey stop technology seventy
years earlier than everyone else I'll
open a portal
this guy explains what he's doing even
though I forget let's just give these
assholes five sins for beating us over
the head with so much exposition
this guy pulls pins on two grenades but
throws them one at a time
there goes Baron von will home from the
Nazi part of the family we don't talk
about him even though evil c-3po is
completely out of bullets and has no
cover no one shoots at him giving him
all the time he needs to show off his
blade nunchucks nameless henchmen
approach one of the time allowing them
to be easily vanquished cliche so the
portal pulls in a light fixture without
affecting it at all then the faceless
henchman gets sucked in and burns up on
impact but now this guy is getting
liquefied and pulled in a drop at a time
it's fine if you want to suck people in
a deep space but at least do it with
some consistency the port has been open
for too long something may have come
through even though all of us were
watching it and surrounding it while it
was open and would have seen something
come through or a Fe makes your ass
butan also that hugh jackman looking
motherfucker is supposed to be Rasputin
did they not have enough access to a
photo of the real Rasputin old-time Baby
Ruth product placement get me up
thinking this guy was ready to fucking
go with that blanket it's a boy it's
just a baby boy these characters have
confused finding a demon creature in an
old abandoned church with the baby being
born I'm not sure how those two black
soldiers got into this platoon
considering the army didn't integrate
until several years after World War two
one full minute long title card Hellboy
comic book based on the rumors of a real
Hellboy based on the script of this
movie which was adapted from the Hellboy
comic book Moldavia doesn't exist
anymore the western half is part of
Romania and the eastern side is the
Republic of Moldova that said the former
principality of Moldavia had a pretty
bitchin flag it's a shame this guide
wasn't suspicious when they asked him
how quickly he bleeds
well you were there when the machine
popped his eyes out right no matter
really I'm just wondering how a thing
that resurrects somebody somehow decides
nah you lost your eyes can't give those
back room Brunton home grows up to be
Doc Brown lungs spine liver room has
cancer basically everywhere but is still
able to stand and move around and
otherwise basically be fine even though
they explained who this guy is ten
seconds ago movie still felt the need to
put his name at the bottom of the screen
also why is a high ranking official for
the FBI on a talk-show discussing this
what's he going to do next dispute the
findings of the Weekly World News waste
management services
no one is suspicious of a waste
management services building that looks
this nice especially in New Jersey hello
I'm John Lee because of course he is
everyone's late but to what consequence
nothing instead of walking all the way
to the counter like a normal person
John decides to stop right on the thing
that he doesn't know is an elevator turn
the pages please if you don't mind this
seems like an incredibly inefficient way
to read waiting for someone to come
along turn the page for you we find out
later this guy can do basically fine
outside water so if he wants to read a
book so bad you should just get out of
the damn swimming pool and even if he
wants to stay in the pool can they not
get an intern who laminate some pages
isn't this what I pay taxes for John
John T Myers Kansas City 76 Abe Sapien
superpowers include breeding underwater
sums form of telekinesis and
expositional rambling April 14 1865 the
day that Abraham Lincoln died Abe
Lincoln died the morning of April 15th
he was shot on the 14th Oh John gets
grossed out by something he's been
within no shadow for some time building
his integrated museum into their Maxwell
Smart style series of doors hallway
that's six times a day he's got a thing
for cats you'll be as nanny his keeper
his best friend he never goes out
unsupervised this guy plays the pronoun
game six times even after he knows for a
fact that John has no idea who he's
talking about he never goes out
unsupervised home they're already deep
underground in a vault can they really
not tell this kid what he's here to do I
hate
comic book was he saying there this
whole time John didn't notice and the
guard giving him all the instructions
talked about him in the third person
like an asshole but he doesn't age like
media he's barely out of his 20s but
he's played by a 54 year old they have
these for you even though he'll boy is
in his early 30s he can still be
influenced by candy stand what his horns
he files them to fit in of all the
flimsy things going on is by far the
flimsiest he's a giant red Duke with the
tail that is basically a demon slash
government prisoner who the fuck is he
trying to fit in with the girl who
spontaneously combusts a better
explanation might be it's easier to put
on shirts without giant horns on your
head to cross the track oh sorry guys I
thought I stumbled into a screen movie
there for a second man
knock me out I need to recollect my
bearings here we're here at the go an
alarm was triggered slow news day one
sheet of glass between them enough story
of my life Abe says this like he's in a
terrarium most of the time but more
often than not he's out walking around
with everyone else by now for instance
just left us red take the hint
we don't take it's not digging its
statue however was Hollow
I'm reliquary not quite a reliquary is a
container that a relic goes in hallow
statue is referred to in the archeology
community as a hollow statute perfect
job for these babies made of myself
where did you learn to make bullets
toontown Abe's telekinesis occasionally
needs to be aided by sticking his
suction cuppy hand to a door behind this
storm a dark entity EVOO ancient and
hungry and easily contained by common
doors hey stinky kitchens closed
Hellboy wastes a lot of time I'm using
himself with one-liners rather than just
killing the dark evil ancient hungry
entity entity's name is Samael the
desolate one son of snare gah brother
ape somehow can't translate the most
important work for Hellboy before he
does battle with this thing or just
decides to cut himself off for fun or
some fairly in this universe moderate
shoves that would simply knock a large
man back a bit send a very large demon
creature halfway across the room
since the holy water bullets didn't work
Hellboy decides a paintball might be
more effective hey crazy costumes huh
ice cover kid
hell fogger so now with people running
in the streets nobody wants to slow down
not one car
I see people slowing down for birds for
Christ's sake I'm fireproof you're not
and yet 42 seconds ago you singed your
finger on a hot horn I'm fireproof
you're not and this monster is death
proof did you forget that also is it the
protocol of a super secret FBI funded
program to just leave dead hellhounds on
train tracks see if touching your hot
horns hurt then why the actual does your
fingers being on fire not hurt at all
Dillon enjoys opera cliche
you know most movies use the lower third
location text to tell the audience where
the characters are not described the set
you bill unless there's a fictional city
called abandoned subway area
in the no longer existent country locker
room now that this guy has glass
marbleize is the movie saying he can see
is the oh it's its tale don't worry
everyone it's just a stale also Bud
Light I'm still mad about Hellboy
killing that monster that can come back
to life and no one bothered to be
concerned whether or not it came back to
life or anything especially this guy I
need to touch it to see do you because
when we first saw you you were able to
tell us everything about John just by
looking at him and when you gave us all
that info about the monster you were
just touching the door of the room he
was in professor they were here boys
here
Nixon Houdini Jimmy Hoffa whoa Jeffrey
Tambor I got this but yeah he's right
enough with the pointlessly cryptic
pronoun game none of these guards are
shooting him either because they've
collectively been waiting for the
opportunity to live out that scene from
Raiders of the Lost Ark or they're all
questioning why as swords are so fucking
loud according to this flashback
Rasputin is the one who gives this hell
helm thing resurrection power so why did
a breed that it already had resurrection
powers for each one of you that falls
to show her eyes didn't Hellboy kill
that thing once and it just came back to
life by itself then he killed it again
and indeed we saw two after that but
shouldn't there be forward by now also
why do the bad guys go through all this
trouble let's create a monster
given resurrection powers and in the
unlikely event it gets killed BAM two
more baby I didn't they just take this
pile of angel tears go back to
headquarters resurrect this hellhound
kill it and let it spawn several times
to create an army also Abe sapiens
powers are officially way too convenient
at this point to be able to simply touch
a sword and have a full HD
professionally edited flashback of what
happened in the museum human fasiq it's
impossible to believe that Abe didn't
know this already and I'm super confused
about his powers does he have to touch
people or things directly to get
information or can he just sense it the
movie says both things are true he
couldn't figure out this guy was sick
until now you've lost a lot of blood he
has blood touched you five seconds laid
three eggs okay this movie is formally
trying to become the most confusing
thing ever made now you're telling me
this monster also lays multiple eggs
that also will become future hellhounds
it's already got the death creates two
more spell on it you're telling me it
reproduces normally too we can't risk it
tomorrow you go back to the tracks with
a group of agents tomorrow why tomorrow
doesn't this feel like something that
should be taken care of now fine those
eggs destroy them when Broome said to
John find those eggs John heard find
some backstory on Liz
Liz's clothes aren't burning off I see I
can help we're basically halfway through
the movie and you have done next to
nothing so far
what is your area of expertise he
doesn't want me with him he'll boy asks
a valid question that the movie doesn't
have an answer for so they smash cut to
the next scene using Hellboy's valid
question to make it seem like he doesn't
like John okay I'm not pure of heart yes
you are so John is Broome's worthy
successor not because he has immense
knowledge of the occult or any real
combat experience or is well-liked by
all the abnormal creatures in the BPRD
but because he's pure of heart you
moving mom I'm saying Dionysus which one
Pope st. Dionysus or st. Dionysus of
Alexandria st. Dionysus of Paris Saint
Dionysus the areopagus
Saint Dionysus of India is Sam's tongue
much shorter in water because we've seen
him use his tongue successfully over
much greater distances on dry land this
guy is definitely going to be killed
because his weapon has two charged fuel
and load
out of the resurrection didn't I kill
you already
Hellboy asks this even though he just
said how that creature was the Hound of
the Resurrection and they've talked
about how it comes back to life the last
time they ran into it trains and movies
always arrive right when a fight occurs
no one down here wants to run away from
the two monsters fighting really man
they can't miss that train no monster
fight has ever made them late and they
ain't starting now
phone ex machina also now that Hellboy
smashed this thing over the hellhound
how's Nico supposed to get back to the
Nebuchadnezzar why not just slide the
box of kittens over to the group of
people holding on to them while you
fight is definitely worse than just
leaving them where you found them I
guess no one explained to help only that
killing these things produces two more
not important information I guess after
stabbing clay approximately 15 times
Cronin's blade and glove miraculously
have no blood on them Hellboy decides to
attack his boss with a hot water heater
which is something I also learned you
shouldn't do the hard way something I
learned in therapy and depressed one
rubber band I'm impatient too so they
taught you when you have bad feelings to
inflict small amounts of pain on
yourself people who work closely with
elbow I haven't been told about his
escape yet and knowing his affection for
Liz seems like they might be the first
people to be called cream and sugar
moron she takes it black
two-and-a-half-hour movie wastes time
exploring Hellboy's unfounded jealousy
rap Hellboy clearly falls and misses the
ledge but somehow didn't fall to the
ground
shagging ice we've been dealing with a
lot of assholes who know how to come
back to life let's just leave their dead
bodies lying around and hope they don't
leave again also even though broom
removed the unexplained electronics that
kept Cronin alive he's able to wake up
for some reason and put himself back
together ah ah considering the distance
Hellboy through that and the speed it
was probably going this probably should
have killed John also we're still
watching John go on a date with Liz
while Hellboy is mad about it movie
proves that it's incredibly hard to look
menacing while walking down a spiral
staircase it's awfully nice of the New
Jersey Times to write a cover story
titled the apocalypse that would be
positioned just so to make sure we
understand what's going on hey guys we
decided to drive out to where we thought
you might be to give you the news of
brooms death rather than just calling it
rainy funeral and black umbrellas shot
from overhead cliche also every
motherfucker at this funeral brought the
same sized black umbrella to this thing
they knew this funeral would be extra
sad because the main character died and
there would be heavy rain since Hellboy
can't attend the funeral he stands on
top of the funeral home where he can
clearly be seen but no one sees him
except for Liz I'm not much of a problem
solver three decades
I've only completed two sides why not
use your magic front lobe that can see
into the past and see what the Rubik's
Cube factory worker did to mess it up
then work in Reverse John walks out of
the important mission meeting to watch
Liz walk down the hall this coffin
survives this no no this is good this is
what the movie was missing a sassy
sidekick also this dead guy that Hellboy
brought back to life told him there was
miles of tunnels underneath here but
after that this bear has been totally
worthless he doesn't know where to go so
why did they even bother to haul him
down here this actually works the people
in this universe must be very slick
Hellboy begins to levitate for a moment
this is about where the door was when
manning slid through which means it
should be closed at this point unless
the door immediately paused and only
began moving again at this moment which
would be very considerate of the door
really Lefty did you cut yourself again
or am I supposed to believe that's the
cut from a moment ago because that cut
clearly happened on the back of your
hand hey hey what's wrong with you
seriously all cronin manages to do in
this situation is not kill anyone and
break his own gramophone also why is
there a rope hanging right over the trap
that's supposed to kill people and one
of the spikes come out after the victim
probably already fell to the ground well
you know feel that way about me you want
to know that here Wow
good question I don't even want to know
it all red white whatever guys are all
the same it sounds like a bad minions
meme about housewives and wine couldn't
they just hook Liz up with a bunch of
grenades and just have her charge in
here and blow all the monsters up she's
like resistant to fire right
where is she only resistant to her own
fire that's a very specific fire
resistant hit me earlier in the movie
Liz said she was beginning to control
her powers yet here she needs to be
slapped around a little in order to get
her flame on also I thought small
instant measured amounts of sharp pain
were supposed to calm her down I'm
legitimately asking is she always
wearing fireproof clothes that seems
expensive she was so desperate to get
the flame going a moment ago but now
she's moseying like those creatures
aren't currently killing Hellboy in fact
he's resistant to fire so they could
have won this a long time ago but they
needed the dramatics of Liz doing a Jean
Grey impression only Jean survives this
thank you for this
not only did John survive but so do
those grenades he can break through
extremely thick stone walls but these
normal sized chains are just too much
your stone implant what did you think it
was made for smashing things lighting on
fire
weird masturbation ah no let me get this
straight
some asshole built a portal to another
dimension that would release some sort
of badass apocalyptic creature but only
during an eclipse but first it required
Rasputin to open this gate in the
beginning of the movie and somehow give
birth to Hellboy who would then one day
grow big enough to use his arm as a key
I mean that is one convoluted prophecy
complete with convoluted carpentry and
witchcraft aboot John is now suddenly
able to slip free from his restraints
does Hellboy saying his real name apply
to everyone's restraints remember who
you are the real you is inside there
somewhere cliche did John just use the
Force to get those rosary beads to
Hellboy even though the monster was
halfway through the portal he just
disappears when it closes
instead of getting chopped in half or
something - lets go maybe you should
handle that situation let's quit coming
out of the evil dude seems like a pretty
big loose end
apocalyptic monster merely tosses hella
boy like a tennis ball instead of just
going ahead and killing him already on
his clothes fireproof - what are the
rules
you
what is it that makes a man a man is it
his origins the way things start sure
that napur testicles JP Prewitt the
world's greatest my welcome to the
desert of the real
it's over 9000
look at the size of that Whammer
he's got a huge talent yes last night I
actually had a dream my flower sack was
abducted and the kidnappers started
sending me muffins in the mail out there
there's a world outside of Yonkers way
out there beyond this hidden town
Barnaby
Alim um the daddy
Klaatu Barada let's go respira man you
got what you deserved
he's alive
I'm fuckin alive